foreign
[Music]
we start in Turkey where after weeks of
anticipation people are casting their
votes in the second round of the
presidential election they are choosing
between President Richard type erdogan
and opposition leader Kemal kilish
darolu erdogan led the first round two
weeks ago but was half a point short of
an outright Victory kilish dirolu is now
being backed by the small far-right
victory party well Sami zaidan is in
Istanbul Sammy you are heading our
special election coverage from Turkey
today is D-Day there is no turning back
is it going to be more erdogan or is
there going to be an upset Sammy take it
away
that's the big question and we this is
our special coverage for a special day
Cyril as we all know history being made
today as voters went to The Ballot Box
for the first time in this country's
political history in the presidential
runoff a second round well the media
banned about talking about anything
related to indications of how the poll
is going who's leading but this is what
there is a big focus on at this hour
turnout and the reports that we got from
many polling stations is that turnout is
looking healthy that's a crucial
question another important indication we
can talk about is that the lines seem to
be moving quickly which might indicate
we'll get a result earlier than we did
in the first round of voting but all of
this coming after an intense day of
final campaigning yesterday so it's all
started our reports from Ankara
as campaigning due to a close the
presidential candidates made their final
push to convince Waters
erdogan ended his campaign in Istanbul
where his political carrier began
stability and continuity have been the
keyword throughout his election campaign
he has promised his supporters a
powerful Emperor's Paris country with a
more assertive role in the international
Arena
this is turkey Century we want to make
this year's Centennial a beginning for a
stronger Nation based on the solid
foundations we have been building for
our nation for the past 21 years
[Music]
but he is now facing his most difficult
challenge his rival Kemal kalistarova a
former accountant backed by abroad
opposition forced erdogan into a second
round runoff a rare setback for erdogan
after winning several elections over the
last two decades Crystal sees the vote
in the runoff is a referendum on the
future direction of Turkey
for your rights for justice and the rule
of law there needs to be prosperity in
every household my aim is to bring
Justice to this country and peace in
every household I want you to be sure of
that
since assuming the office as the leader
of the people's Republican party
calistogram has lost several elections
against erdogan but determined to defeat
erdogan six opposition parties have
joined forces for this presidential
election with kalistarily chosen as the
immunity leader but erdogan led in the
first round with 49.5 percent of the
world while cholesterol received 44.9
percent neither president erdogan Nordo
could secure enough votes to win in the
first round that result was expected by
many but the main surprise was the
highway for the Nationalist parties many
now believe they could be the king
makers in the runoff and that has forced
the presidential candidates to
reconsider the election campaign
to attract the Nationalist Woods the
mild-man the opposition leader Khalid
focuses his second round campaign on the
anti-refugee sentiments promising to
send home millions of Syrian Afghan and
Pakistani refugees
syrians will go was one of the main
slogans written on billboards
as a result the leader of the ultra
nationalist Victory party
umitosda has announced his support for
kalistarova
but sinanogan another ultra-nationalist
presidential candidate who came third in
the first round has decided to support
president erdogan in the runoff
the preliminary results will be
announced hours after voters cast their
ballots
turkey will either continue with
president erdogan or choose a new leader
but this election will be closely washed
especially by refugees grappling with
fear and uncertainty rasu Sardar Al
Jazeera Ankara to have the intense last
minute campaigns motivated people to
come out to the polling stations one of
the issues we can now talk about with
cinem Kosovo olushi joins us from
uskodar in Istanbul and said them you're
outside the school where the president
will vote later take us through the
turnout how's that shaping up there
well Sami in every election Turkish
president comes and votes here in
Istanbul as he is from Islam lives close
by and this neighborhood I can say is
relatively conservative many of them are
the ruling party supporter president
erdon supporter and in the early hours
of this morning people started to come
here to cast their ballots and having
checked other schools having spoken to
people we see that they are uh they have
an appetite to cast there but because
this election the second round is easier
than the first round as people will be
voting only for the president they will
be choosing only between two people
and the Japanese are done this means
they don't have long papers that they
have to fold and put in the envelope it
is easy for them that's why we are
hearing that when people get inside the
classrooms in polling stations like this
behind me it takes less time for them to
finish it because in the first round
that took place two weeks ago it was
taking a long time for people to cast
their ballots they had two papers voting
for both the Parliamentary members and
the president now it's easy for them and
we're expecting a a good turnout in the
second round because this is what we
hear about the Turkish boats that came
from abroad of course they haven't been
counted yet they will be counted after 5
PM local but the turnout is even larger
than the first round Simon so many
expect people will show their world in
the ballot boxes by choosing between
long-standing President the opposition
and the opposition Challenger back to
you Sami
indeed thanks so much synonym
this is as synonym was explaining a key
election for a key player in global
Affairs an election which will play out
right across turkia Alexia O'Brien takes
us through some of the key spots to look
out for
Istanbul Ankara and Izmir are turkies
biggest cities and in the election
earlier this month all the provinces
around those cities here in red voted
for the opposition candidate Kamal
kalichterol you that's a shift away from
Richard type erwan who took both Ankara
and Istanbul in 2018. but this year he
lost those provinces by about one or two
percentage points and there was a much
wider margin in Izmir however it
traditionally votes for the opposition
erdogan didwin as expected in the
central conservative Heartland here in
yellow his party's support base but with
fewer votes compared to 2018
he also won an eight of the 11 provinces
badly affected by those earthquakes in
February analysts suggests that's
because of the governing party's promise
to rebuild the devastated cities further
south east is where most of the Kurdish
population is concentrated the main
pro-kurdish party under the green left
Banner through its support behind
kalichirolu and Kurdish voters followed
suit
then there's Western Europe where the
vast majority of the Turkish diaspora
lives and its 3.4 million registered
voters about 55 percent of those cast
ballots in the runoff vote that's even
more than in the May 14 election when 57
of them voted for Erawan and the
candidate who finished third in the
first round senen Owen won about five
percent of votes overall he has endorsed
Erawan to win
but it's unclear how Owen's supporters
will vote in the runoff and what that
will mean for these two men and their
political ambitions
so in an overcast day here in Istanbul
it's the incumbent who heads into this
election with momentum something off you
could frame as Cloudy with a Chance of
continuity we'll be here all day
bringing you updates as the election
unfolds but for now I'm gonna hand you
back to Doha
[Music]